pleasure to have years of talking about
machine learning and automa
reason oh thank Alo thanks to the
organizers for inviting me
here um so this is a lot of stuff done
this many people
but St out among them my coor of many of
these things in last
five years also so I'll try
to give you some some high level
motivation examples of what we are
doing so that you can use it for your
own learning hopefully hopefully train
yourself and uh more more of these
things uh so in general uh you can ask
questions any time uh I'm I've given
this talk uh too many times in a fairly
high level way so I'm happy Focus some
some of the things in in more deta way
Flor Flor wants me to show it how the
features exactly look
Etc um so so this is of one slide about
the high level
motivation which is
like pretty ous like what should be the
components of the altimate system which
will automate mathematical scientific
thinking and uh like at least in my
opinion you you need a lot of
capabilities like pattern matching
analogy like we were talking about it in
the previous already induction from
examples like this thing which is in
generally called
maybe I would IND inductive
thinking obviously you you need
inductive freezing like without
without free you will you will finish
that proof or at
least correct
proof and like we we all know that these
two things
somehow uh go on in Our Minds when we
when we
to some somehow there is feedback
and we we also use a lot of knowledge
when the doing this sort of stuff
so
uh we have the capability to to very
quickly reject some idea B A of previous
experience for
examp uh
so
the one uh good uh Corpus
where uh at least doing this sort of AI
research
seems mly
plausible is this formal mathematics
SL libr formal theorems and obviously
today like with the sort of General
progress in AI people are also thinking
about doing this on top of totally
informal like St
but at least when I was thinking about
this some say 15 20 years ago the the
let's say the natural langage processing
methods learn far enough to let's say
take a huge purpose of naturally written
mathematics
and do some sort of Fairly deductive
science of
that so so it seems to me that doing it
in two steps or today possibly somehow
combin
and and F develop like fairly good
reasoning methods over totally
for and then try to align it with
informal math is is a sort of more
scalable
approach part still
today uh so
uh on Friday there was this discussion
where go something like uh proof
assistant is what a mathematician would
think it is it's definitely something
which would use for
you
and I I took it as a fairly critical
comment while like saying
that uh automated here improving
definitely is
today something which would be uh in
general useful to mathematicians and
then that there were other people
talking about the S of flourishing
Traditions so I'm I'm definitely on the
Tim go side and I I think
maybe uh linking back to
the historical overiew which happened on
Friday uh I think the the soring syn
point today in
automatic is is this
intuition intuition based methods which
at some point I think
Larry uh Larry was who obviously I
everybody has to admire him so something
like capturing ution is too hard for us
so so let's try to do the inferencing
parts of of the uh
automated uh reasoning
processes and obviously you can do a lot
of This research when you do symmetric
raking by I know likeing
for equality Etc at some point you run
out of these ideas the theories become
too complex and like
basically uh things today end up in a
Brute Force search which is totally
lacking of any
so
to to give you a some sort of
flavor what I would consider to be to be
flourishing uh flourishing uh
AI research
today are things like this
like very recent for example AI think uh
humans in in
poker
um some some time ago like mome beating
humans in
Jeopardy obiously this one this one made
it made a b splash
go and I like this like 10 years old
um standard people basically the first
breakthrough s driving cars so so that's
what I would consider to be like
flourishing uh
flourishing automated
today and basically all the examples
which I showed you are
because to a large extent they do
something this they manag to
learn so I think I'm sort we are
currently still
really so to it's it's interesting that
like in the history overview on
Friday uh we we had all these people
starting with her Simon
and etc etc but but actually I I think
Alan uring was uh was the guy who who
really uh was thinking about this in
um in a very relevant way for
today uh so as you all know he he did
this paper in I 1936 where which is
still toing interpreted as like the is
being hard for the halting problems
undecidable
Etc but he he went probably through aot
of development during
the hecking years where it used
thisal methods and
in in 1950 he basically established
artificial
intelligence and uh
he he basically says there uh something
like uh we may hope that machines will
eventually compete this plan all Pur
intellectual
Fields say say that knowing is
1936 and uh appes to humans as well say
unability result applies to humans as
yeah and uh the well some people might
object right
um so and he actually established like
the last chapter of his of his book
there of his paper is on learning
machines where
the uh so sort of in a very Visionary
way
something uh which has been lar largely
happening in theing of the AL system
menu uh
really
train a game playing
engine uh on on good human human games
and then it to against s
self so if if I would be giving an
historical overview to I would
definitely mention him as sort of the
grandfather or Godfather of what has
been uh
happening um so so that's that's the
sort of large uh light
scale motivation
and um and obviously like there are all
these Blue Sky Visions like like sort of
Str AI by looking at this l
formal libraries um but also like as you
have seen in just talks like people I
actually you can help some people at
least a bit today with with ofation over
over all these liaries
like make uh make that formalization
faster uh I I I should say the
uh again like I I believe that the
reason why we have successfully develop
reasoning over very large libraries is
that we are not doing for search we for
example U so so this is some uh some
sort
of uh bigger plan how how
this how this project developing AI over
laral libraries has been attack for some
time so so we try to translate these
libraries into strong reasoning which we
have
today and then
uh we obviously test and evolve various
Ai and machine learning and the tools
for them and
then if if it works to well them
obviously stronger and stronger or more
and more difficult
benchmarks and like we really have like
dozens of benchmarks
today uh so now I will go through some
of the tasks that that are sort of
strongly related to to the rest Ai and
uh machine learning
tasks
so let's say in 2002
2003 I really translated the whole mizar
library in a way that I could get it
to the
automated which were uh available at the
time like just to give you an idea the
TP standards on the
standard the translation I did was the
DFG format which was used by the system
which was one of the best
for for the particular kinds
ofs
and some uh you could see that that this
is not totally possible but you
can uh
prove quite a few of the sort of mire
top level practically all of the very
low levas
with these automated
fers uh but the tasks for for which the
aps were totally unar at the time uh was
that when you give them something like
80,000 lemas and ask them please prove
the please prove the next
one uh so uh the eventually we started
to call this task of please uh select
from from the library
the the set of slos which is as small as
possible and gives the highest possible
chance to
period uh premise
selection and obviously you could say
that this is some like magic because
this is obviously some undecidable task
right if if you make it finite
expon uh
and the surprising thing uh that we know
pretty well today is that uh this this
is really not something
magical uh the mathematical texts on
these libraries of
TRS behave
pretty similarly to to for
example natural language
text like there is a lot of repetition
there is a lot of stuff that you can you
can learn by statistical machine
learning
methods which which allow you to
reasonably predict when when given the
next
conjecture uh the set of facts that will
be useful for doing it so so so already
here when somebody tells you like this
is a magical totally unaccessible
property of
mathematicians like we we have pretty
pretty good data saying that this is in
many cases not the
case uh so so for example this proof
advisor really like 14 years old now is
is just
a very simple machine learning method
called my very simple frequen the
things which you where you basically
take
uh all the facts in the
library from each fact you extract some
features in this case just the symbols
like just symol like
plus and for each of the
facts you associate to to these
features the the set
of uh previous lemas which I used to
prove that so so that would be your out
labels so so for each
proved Lemma in your library you will
basically get one training example
associating the features and the sort of
set of names of L which I to and that
gives you a training set of let's say 30
50,000 examples on on that you run your
favorite machine learning method and
obviously you do it in a way that you
train on some data some other data and
you you measure the
performance so if done in this sort of
very simplistic uh uh way already you
get something like
this 70%
coverage of the first um of of the
needed uh premises in the in the first
100 recommendations sort of your your
first 100 Google HS for
this and like like if you if you use
this as a very
rudimentary sort
of selected for
the then at the time like giving it
toing all
uh
so over the years like this is is data
from about 3 years
ago this has been improved to about 45
to% the not
just I have this B which I made three
years ago I think is pretty conservative
so if you want to let me
let what do you attribute the
Improvement sorry what do you attribute
that Improvement
to uh yeah so uh so here is one
picture
uh so so for example this shows you how
the better machine learning
methods uh much much
faster give you the the right set of
lemas from the
library and uh I could show you maybe
next picture actually so you're coming
to it anywhere you can yeah yeah so so
on this picture you can see that it
matters so so the sooner you get the
right set of
lmas U
the battery for you because typically
like all these guys be great uh if you
if you give them too too many like
that's currently that's in the nature of
how all these guys like not not
just basically any
Al currently Expos to
manyy done answer I well sort of yeah
can you go back to the slide
yeah so uh these features look kind of
weak I they yeah they are yeah so that's
because you're using the explicit
symbols and the explicit names and so on
yeah there is I was actually looking for
something like this pattern of the
P so so so another answer to your both
questions is that like you can
obviously build in a lot of intelligence
into how how we characterize
mathematical uh objects right like what
what is a similarity between two two
statements uh so basically like nobody
knows exactly but we for example know
that uh like just using symbols is where
is than for example using all
subterms possibly with some variable
matching if you are just keeping them as
strings or if
you if you for example characterize each
formula uh but by the set of all terms
in
them
um and uh all their unifications or or
all their possible generalizations
because again that tells you like this
this particular sofware can be matched
or unified with that particular sofware
so or like the one thing which we do not
have here is actually what I was
mentioning during the previous
St validity models like if you if you
have a big set of models like typically
use finite models because same definite
mod is is
stuff uh
then evaluating each formula in a well
chosen set of let's say 1,000 models and
and
using these 1,000 values as some sort of
characteristic Vector of characterizing
this particular formula gives you a sort
of totally different um feature based
characterization of
of mathematical statements than for
example just looking at it
syntactically U so or like very recently
the the Google guys took
U took um a formula to be really just a
string of
characters or just just string of
tokens and uh then the the idea is that
um
you you try to train a neural network
which which would which is recurrent so
sort of sees sees the
context and uh you train it
simultaneously with the premise
selection task so so somehow this thing
is called
embedding U the the the strength of
characters or the strength of tokens
becomes a vector of real Valu for
100 or 1,000
block uh that's
Vector which which is somehow magically
trained using the sort of deep learning
stuff U to to have features which are
useful for for
kind I I should say that that it I we
hoped uh that it would work for example
reasonably well as it does for examp
image recognition today at some point
you really get very high level features
there like
protal uh cow or dog or whatever we are
not sure we we are doing that at this
moment uh another thing which sort of
was tried there was for example
to uh to expand definitions so so
instead of uh taking symbols as
a opaque object which is just a name or
string uh you can you can take the
embedding for for the definition of that
symbol and sort of recursively unfold
all the symbols using their inen in
these formas and that that also gives
you some sort of much more semantic
treatment of of all the objects or all
the characters and strengths in your
formulas because somehow the idea is
that the ining will
some uh well I'm not sure if K
is oh you can
ask um so so so that that's sort of the
digression about features uh what's
what's behind this progress um so so
definitely uh better and better focusing
on on the right side of flas helps helps
you a lot so to to give you an idea we
can or let's say three four years
ago we could by by using all the weapons
we
had uh and I mean something like 3 weeks
of CPU time on a reasonable server we
could prove something like
40% of of the misar
theorems than than given the full
previous Library like in this really way
when you always allow the the full
previous library to be taken into
account U but by sort all sorts of
cheating we can we can Pro something
like
56% uh so for example looking really at
the human written proof and and trying
to to uh to use it for cutting down set
of eligible
L and uh so now we have the set of let's
say
30,000
misar lemas which we know how to prove
by using I like
PES and uh because uh
we we know the sort of ATP proof we can
we can minimize it we can really
exhaustively uh try to remove all the
Redundant lemas from the
TRS and rerunning the minimiz set this
basically any theor today gives us
something like I don't know
95% these GRS in in very little time
so it it really matters very very
significantly if you if you can do do
this guessing uh much much much
better so yeah so anyway this picture is
just some sort of comparison of the of
the various kind of selection methods
like
question on one hand I agree with you
that I mean if we could do the guessing
much better we have a higher success
rate but some point to do the guessing
much better we basically have to do the
proof and then we don't need the pro
anymore is what I would think or do you
agree or not with that statement I mean
if we're really really good at guessing
I mean at some point the best way to
guess is to actually do the proof and
and find it and then you guess it right
right I mean you understand what I'm
saying oh it makes sense to put so much
energy in relevance filter instead of
the pro
afterwards uh so so so what what I said
was I'm not sure if it's in conflict
with what you are saying but what I said
is that it took us like something like
one
month
of
CPU time on a server to get to 40
person whereas if we if we have it today
uh then we can use let's say 1 hour
of CPU time on the same
server to get let's
say so so this was sort of the I
thinking about your comment about 95% I
interpreted it as so
so so so what we have
today this let's
say these numbers have been changing but
stating and if I let's
say well 95% or 56% is a bit more than
this right like this is just a estimate
like it's it's it's about like this so
so this is using sort of very little
search but once you have it once you
have the the relevant L like the at
least the M GRS but also the f
but uh go go through really really
easily uh
so
something so so your question is like
when when does the machine learning
become so complicated that it's better
to to fact well something like this or
or are these are these two different
problems or because some
sense some sense relevance filtering is
about doing the proof as an abstract
sloppy level yeah I I agree like I I
think uh so that's by the way one of my
first points that we should really do
these so sort of induction and deduction
together then build systems which be
done
together and for example what worked in
subzilla quite a bit is that people run
uh the sub Sol for some time then EXT
features from from the partial
unfinished pruns and that gives them
better idea of what what strategies that
they should be running whatever this
many uh
so um I S basically agree lot like the
these things should be done together and
already like the way like systems like
malaria they they are up together you
you you have to finish quite a few Pro
so that you can learn from them so that
you can use the Learned knowledge to
finish more proes and and then again you
learn from those and
okay um
okay oh
so this is again another slightly oldish
picture where basically you take the
premise
selections and you again link them to to
an
automated Empire in this case and you
can sort of see the the better machine
learning uh methods from the previous
picture and this C some based machine
learning give
the quite better chance but there are
also some other interesting things so
for example this science system by
uh wasn't really uh performing so well
here um so so you can see that here it
looks it really
sucks uh
whereas uh whereas here the performance
isn't so bad and it for example at some
point reaches the
performance that's
machine so so that probably tells you
something
about
how uh sort of funny and wild is this
domain that you can really get many many
different proofs for for a particular
LMA and just the fact that you memorize
uh some proof doesn't mean that somebody
uh can Inc some some sort of strategy or
come up with
a particular method in this case for
example five times for for the automa
Peri uh which
will produce alternative
Pro you look at how me so I assume the
x-axis is
n
oh this is the number of premises use so
so you get the machine learner and it
tells you like this is the ranking of
premises and then slice it various so of
those how many were actually used in
grps were they all used oh no so so was
that
some oh well like so
the intention so so the
minimization gives you something like
this so so when you when you find the
proofs you can still minimize them
and if you minimize them it typically
leads to to finding the TRU much much
faster and
later um so so just the fact that that
an automated F pro has found a proof
using let's say 50
premises uh doesn't mean that this is
the sort of ultimate uh ultimate result
like like from 50 premises you can very
often go to something like 30 premises
no but it may be a a measure on the
ranking that maybe uh the ranking could
be improved to uh get more problems with
fewer
premises uh yeah yeah so if you if you
rerun this U then definitely things
improve so so so that really L leads to
to the the
various um sort of metals which are
which are around
this um so this is a slide which you
have already seen
uh from Justman so so today we believe
we have something like 45% Su rate on
the top level am us but as I said like
some of these data are quite old now so
we should them a very recent
result of Cesar kishik andash Cha is a
useful and working Henry
F then uh they got something like
40% success rate on reconstruction so so
they can
really get the proof going through the
carel in in 40% cases of the co
standard
library and the interesting thing about
it for the constructivist among you is
that they they get the proofs using
vampire and Etc and they they get like
50% of them and then they some but not
to to
my so this is done on
the uh and obviously the the challenging
thing there is the translation go going
from to
and various
methods uh so so these are the sort of
high level premise selection uh
things I should I I've probably spoken
about some of these things
already uh so so for example we we have
this semantic features which uh en cold
term matching and unification which
things quite a bit for for the machine
Learners
uh a
fairly simple Improvement but still
giving all of
performance
are fairly old statistical methods like
this frequency index frequency and this
like indexing which from your set of
sparse
features uh create some sort of weighted
in the case of like semantics of
dance dance
vectors uh
which generalize better in some
sense uh C and got here recently did
this very nice work
on uh basically statistical matching U
between uh different libraries where the
concepts can have very different names
and they can they might not even
correspond to one
another
exactly but it's it's it's done on a on
a nice statistical level when you
basically abstract the symbol names from
from all
formulas uh for each symbol you get the
formulas abstracted formuls which hold
about it and then
you basically say the two symbols are
similar if the set of abstract with
lenos about them uh have a high
overlap uh and then then you
match the the highest overlaps against
each other and you instantiate and you
run the algorithm again and this really
allows them to import um lemas from
let's say m four or Isabel into whole
light and vice
versa uh doing some sort of super Hammer
where you might either trust the import
the FL off or you could try to recurs
through it
and import
vibrating U we can actually also use
this technology for conjecturing so you
can take just one
library and uh
find matches between different theories
there or at Le syntactically different
theories there like imagine you have
multiplicative groups and additive
groups and in the same library then then
this sort of matching technology will
will allow you to transport the
L for
thetive groups
try uh
lemmatization um
that's a method where you you don't just
look at the graph of P level Ms but you
look at all the sort of low level M
which for example fly is like a on those
and you do some some very fast methods
like for example pay trank for
um
quickly um extracting the sort of top
top candidates like taking the 1 billion
to like 10
millions and then basically doing the
section also with them augments
your your set of facts that you can for
the things
and
I maybe the maybe the last one is
interesting uh so that's basically that
we no longer use um just the automated
F but we program the interactive fers to
to
statistically based on the current sub
goal uh use active with appropriate
parameters so so imagine you are doing
something like your whole light light
proof and you run some induct tactic
that leaves you with some sub goals and
then for for these sub goals you sort of
statistically in this case s look up in
in a huge database of of all previous
sub goals which uh sub goals match
matches
and then you sort of try to run the
tactic with the parameters from from
those things so so this uh reserves high
level
statistical search on the Tactical level
improves quite a bit also just the of
Hardcore
translation
um I have mentioned this already
this is this is just a table if somebody
is interested about how many uh features
you can get um on on the me library and
it's a small this is like 2007
to8 from the
library
library uh if if you use these various
feature extraction methods
so uh
for for symbols it's it's not too
much uh whereas if you if you go
into some sort of terms for example
subterms then or this unification
features then you can you can get really
five few here but still what like the
the speeds of of the very uh simple
machine learning algorithms like
uh low level guidance so so obviously
because these things work for for these
libraries in a high level way M try to
put them really at the core of the
automated uh so Mario was saying that
I'm inventing funny names so apart from
malaria we invented also m
M
um um so M so often has this me
connection and it's it's really
surprisingly
efficient uh connection based
F written in a very compa way like I
don't know 100 times maybe you can the
main code can
bees uh and it has surprisingly good
performance on on the the first lar The
Benchmark which I created in
2006 it beat which which at the time was
was this really C
implemented pride of thecan
people uh so uh so so we took took this
link
up and put again a fairly simple uh
machine learn not na base
into the basically the main determinism
point
there uh which is when you when you are
extending the the Tableau Branch you
have some sort of tip of the branch
where you can
unify say with all the closes which are
in your
problem and obviously the idea would be
to use the machine learn to tell which
which closes
you f some priority on that and the time
like this
experiment uh
we we couldn't really run it properly
because the machine learning it was
horribly slow it was like 1,000 times
slower than the pr inference engine but
if we really tried hard and just
measured the abstract time like so the
number of steps it takes you to get to
the proof instead of measuring the real
time then then we got on average about
20 Time pro search shortening so so the
of proof search over the
250 charge prams Al short and plan
times uh so we did this uh efficiently
in
2015 creating this fairly efficient male
cup or female cup and that really show
showed us like we we still were quite a
bit slower than than the core
but not so much slower we were like 40%
slower and we got about 50%
more
PRS training on on the previous programs
and
applying um the very recently this is
paper this year
M that something even more sophisticated
this connection to
uh with reasonable results and we are
reinforcement you
get selection as
a side effect so typically no typically
we we don't use this um so so we uh for
example for mop we did this on the MTP
challenge problems but on the small
variant of those problem so we
um we do not take we do not allow all
the previous lops from the library we
limit it to theas which we know are
sufficient for the pro because like
these things we we consider them to be
sort ofal like like the high high level
premise selection and you could also try
to combine but we we didn't want to
reinvent premise selection using
this is the time taken by the training
each time
so could you persist the information
that's learned between
mods to understand what
theist could you could you reuse the
training
results so so we do that uh so for
example for female Cod it's a it's a
huge database of the of the decisions
which you have S of for example of f we
we did it even for the whole libr so so
you get something like
15,000 problems solved
BYO uh and on on that on every decision
we we we serve record the decision and
then we when we get a new problem it's
it's a it's it's a pretty challenging
technological issue to to reduce the
database to the size when it's not
big for for guiding it on on a so so
there are actually stages to in order to
to make this
1,000 and much
smaller so so again this is Cesar is
very good work on on making
making uh you can also do this
for state-ofthe-art uh situation based
uh sys so this is very recent basically
last year and this year very efficient
learning based guiding machine or Enigma
which we now have for
E where we train a very fast linear
classifier to to sort of separate the
the good and the bad Clauses which
regenerates and we really compile this
linear
evaluator into into e because we we need
it to be very very
fast and again we get a immense number
of negative examples and the positive
examples are the Clauses which are
useful for the proof so we do we do the
learning content like in this case it's
it's pretty fast just regr with some
some of the
the again a
pretty interesting thing is how how do
you design the features of these Clauses
to to be reasonably quickly extractable
yet giving you amount of
information and
then a fairly important thing is also to
combine it with the sort of more
standard way how how e evaluate sces
if if you just do it only by Machine
learning sometimes you you get a very
big CL evaluate it as positive which
sort
of uh if you do it all the time uh might
the
situation in aable so you need put some
some
B symbol like this so so
this uh this is the first we got like on
the aim problems which is of long Runing
project we
something so I could talk on and on I
should stop at some point so so there
are all these self evolving met systems
which I already mentioned
is this systems when you solve some
problems learn from
it the learning gives you better premise
selection better so sort
of stics like Enigma
inside so so you can run it on the UN
problems
again uh Sol some more problems learn
from it again Etc ET so
this feedback learning and theing
uh
then there's this uh blind strategy
maker which Picture Tells you more
probably so uh you want to grow a set of
uh good and possibly fairly different ad
strategies for for all these complicated
like for
example and
so you you you want to do something like
evolution
then the strategy are like like these
girs for example and and the uh the
problems are that food and if the
giraffe specializes
better uh on on some problems which
cannot be eaten by by the other ones
then giraff is more fat and more
evolved uh so I'll just show you some
pictures so these
are uh these are the training problems
you use
1,000 training prams for for this
evolutionary thing so you start with
some e
strategies which can solve something
like 5700 problems from the 1,000 and
then we we have like three versions of
this BL strategy maker this is first
version these are two new versions and
as they evolve and evolve and evolve
they they solve more more and more
Problems by developing the new
strategies uh so this is on the training
problem comparison with on on the
testing prams which there's like 400
from
them where we compare
vampire and the outle of
E
around4 numers
um and uh
finally well I'm not sure if I shouldn't
skip it so I'll just tell you that one
thing we are also doing using all all
this sort of speack of premise selection
Ai and machine learning is to try to
learn the informal to formal translation
that we really in the end hopefully be
be able to to understand mathematical
books for
and the primary example was was this uh
book by Tom HS which really corresponds
to to this fpec development where you
can really align it like this it's like
invisible this is the for informal stuff
these are the formal light definitions
which
align and then we we do basically
statistical natural language think we
doing some sort of reasonable reasonable
parsing uh of the two things and in the
end like we disain it the aligned cpose
of the inal
formal uh
formulas and the system which we
have show you
the
uh the demo is doing something like this
so so you type in a reasonably informal
formula then you uh run on it the sort
of statistically trained
par thousands of
previous
examples uh then then you sort of Tye
check it using the whole light type
checking
procedures the the things which go
through the type checker
are given to the to the ho Hammer to
the Hammer we are developing for flly SP
and some some of the pares can be easily
disproved iation basically the first one
and here you can see that the second one
is the one which can really
impr
um uh
some
the
library but you also really have like
all these
other this igation which for example
this C sign is is just a complex version
of sign and this CX is casting
number so so you can also understand it
like like
this so the the ordering is by
sta yeah when when it says no
advice the whole is too stupid but it
seems that the example you have here is
the real version from another
one complex and then oh don't ask me why
artificial intelligence let see see if
the no advises are should have been
disproved last
oh if if obviously we are doing it with
with with small resources so I I think
uh we are giving it like 10 seconds for
each each of these guys and like 10 10
seconds are distributed into I don't
know how many strategies and T Etc
so uh like if we throw more resources
into it something which you
as as obvious should probably be be
proven or disproved but
um I cannot guarantee this
is uh we have some funny examples
actually
uh I
think might something
like this
one so so this
one um
was
it yeah maybe
this yeah so so you you can understand
the oh yeah uh so so so this minus- xals
x you can obiously understand you're
using many many possible interpretations
of minus minus like a vector or a matrix
Etc so so here it turns out
John has formalized it for square
matrices and there's the theor about it
Matrix NE neck but you can also prove it
for rectangular
matrices and he doesn't have the
statement in the
library so so actually our our
fific and then this ambiguation
procedure in this case behaves like a
conjecture because it took a statement
which was um at it to uh non
generally
specifically that then it Fifi it and
then after the disambiguation we
actually get the generalization to the
rectangular matrixes which which takes
longer to prove because the libr theor
isn't there so after joh joh saw this he
actually added
it anyway I should be finished uh so
there is lots of challenges and we all
know them so I on them there is a
growing number of people involved in all
of this people in PR in hbook
Al so if you are interested then this is
the conference to go to we will be
organizing in France French house next
march it will be the
third Sho of that conference and also if
you are very interested feel free to
visit us
[Applause]
in so you do your experiments on
libraries that already have all formally
Pro right so when I do formalization
generally what I discover is I need
lemas that are not there and then I add
them then you then say okay my system is
very successful it has all the levas it
needs available already so I'm saying
something like that what I'm not saying
anything you saying 40% 50% 56% yeah so
finding
out what theas are that you should
need uh this kind of machine learning
fizziness might make that harder maybe
this is uh very interesting so we uh we
do this conjecturing stuff using all all
sorts of all sorts of techniques and the
main technique which we are currently
trying is this sort of
statistical
alignment so so once you have
seen a theorem done from your
multiplicative groups you you will sort
of know how to do it for your addited
groups so that's the idea we we the
statistical analogies they are often
very imprecise and often they help you
so so Tio has recently tried to train
it on a database of whole four theor
like this number of whole four the using
this B training set and this big
evaluation set and then he he just by
this sort of conjecturing
procedure uh he gets uh I
think
200 like 390 out of
735 not exactly know what is this
graph so so I agree with you that's
speculating the the right lemas for for
that theorem which is too far away is
definitely at least today one of the
main tasks we should we should be
attempting so I I think this yes is that
basically to find out what lers are you
need you shouldn't speculate you should
just do the proof and find out where you
get
stuck um so not just randomly start
generating interesting levas because
they might be useful but more like okay
um follow the of the protic for a while
oh apparently I need this we we we
obviously try to do that uh like the the
the methods how to do that are not there
yet so like I'm I'm not going to tell
you that we have soers
because as you know I'm more user of pro
systems and I have a
question I want to to tun tool based on
this kind of AI method and so I'm stting
a l which I consider fairly easy but too
LA to prove it would be the
case I to kind of method and then and
then the tactic
things what what am I supposed to um
should I run it again with a different
configuration I
manually and declare that it's
not there's something I'm missing here
workflow that so so the the sort of
classical workflow is this sort of
Sledgehammer workflow where Larry toiled
quite a bit to pour Jo her's metis into
into his to to have it reasonably
reconstructed in
but I I have maybe the wrong feeling
that um for for automate um decision
procedures I can have a very rough idea
that okay it's a linear algebra frag
plus some yeah so that is sort of maybe
I I I would definitely fall for things
where you need induction when you need
decision procedure like I I think the
way how we just did it with ttic to when
you are
uh a class a reasonably big class of
problems which are reasonably uniformly
discharged with some fairly similar
sequences of tactic invocations I I
think learning statistical technical
search is is definitely going to be for
you like that sort
of maybe I can add something because I
I'm both developer end user Cham and the
short answer is yes we tryam 30 seconds
or how much P patient would have and if
it fails we start and kind of EAS our
proof with several steps and then we
recursive C sled hammer and then we you
know go as deep or as Shadow so I
remember at one point had and usually
after you use it for some time I mean at
some point I was able to predict like
this will take two seconds this take 20
seconds it will CL out and I was very
good at my prediction but once to the
point where I could even stop calling s
and waiting I mean just in my
head your
person
Sy but anyway and so the machine is
training you
right and so I mean so so when I'm
saying if you can bring only one tool
with you on the island it shouldn't need
St Hammer because that to either
succeeds or fail and same thing with any
of those tools I think that like hly
hammer and so on uh I mean you really
get nothing back when it fails and you
have to be ready to do a manual appr
nonetheless still saves you a lot of
work and we also have measurements out
in the wild you know like
the4 people like measured for six months
on 20 machines like how often they were
calling that Jammer what's the success
rate and so on and was about 40% so like
out in the wild so they counted yeah my
my feeling was just that
it was harder to predict when it more
have it it is harder but predict get to
I mean I was really surprised with that
example was like there was one statement
in the real numbers was okay and almost
instantaneous yeah and then you lift it
to complex number like syntactically and
it fails well it depends on
the yeah it's
randone it's not randone blah blah
I think somebody should be deciding
the ohry he had hand up a long
time okay uh do you see a difference
between uh various areas of mathematics
or computer science here have you done
statistics where are you best I I I
think the the most statistics was shown
by uh J and his talk like then the
sledgehammer machine learning Pap really
has the the
various things going from probability
Theory to to some sort of Hardcore
computer science whatever it is some
protocols G ja
Etc so I I think one but again justment
is here I I'm mostly interested in
mathematics
not I I mean I'm happy if we can help
computer scientists but um I I think the
the general idea which I'm getting from
from those
evaluations is that
um SMP solers like C C4 for example Z3
are sort of getting better and better on
on the sort of more computer science
Parts uh whereas on the on the
mathematical Parts you still have quite
a bit of quantification Etc so the sort
of traditional superposition based autom
are still still
better uh somebody already said that the
the proofs in CS are much more shallow
and boring and the F formulas are wrong
because you the full memory model of
something that's horrible but as in math
the statements are short and the
ET so so where does f spec fall oh fly
spec is interesting because we we do the
evaluation mostly only on the textual
part we if if we took into account the
the sort of computational part of flyp
then the numbers would be very very
different but the the for example the
nonlinear equations for fly SP that's
like 6,000 of CPU hours
uh whereas the textual part is like two
hours two CPU hours so all all this sort
of machine learning would be very very
different if we took took
into
sorry so I guess regarding question like
can
you report to the user in any useful
manner information about your partial
search which was terminated because you
ran out of time I think there was
another talk which discussed like Lem
selection for user face pures so so so I
like long long long time ago I did this
proof advisor where I said like okay I'm
I'm getting something like 14% here
that's not very useful so let's just
give um to to the Misa
users the the most relevant lemas which
will
um tell them like these are the things
you might be doing at this current point
of view and I honestly do not
know why they didn't use it like I think
it's sort of was useful to me at least
but uh the the one or are users which I
got at the time uh told me later that
really uh combining it with the AP
search which tells you these are the
eight lemas and the proof follows from
them is is much
much nicer information for them than
just these 10 lemas might be useful for
you but it could be like some sort of C
which like maybe I should have
visualized the L better orever I I I
don't
know like we we we still like what Kya
was saying that they they cannot
evaluate the stuff like this stuff
definitely can be evaluated in the sort
of machine learning sort of look at the
at the coverage of how many good hands
you have you you can improve on the
machine learning site Etc so I I
personally think that this sort of
Google Google for a um formalize should
be a useful thing regardless of whether
you actually prove the thing or you
don't Pur this is my one experience but
I mean you could look at the output so a
saturation based theem C and very often
it might be might have derived Clauses
that are that have just one literal and
you could speculate those as conjectures
negation of those as conject an example
I had recently which I found very
frustrating is I had this go look at I
thought okay will do it it then I zoom
it broken down and there was always one
goal that failed broke it down broke it
down broke it down all the way down to
uh if you apply this if you convert a
set to multi set and the multi set back
to a set is the identity and then s was
failing even on that and I couldn't get
C examples but it turned out there was
one if you take an infinite set the M
set have R finite and not reflected in
the name of the data structure just
confuse you uh so I spent one hour you
know zooming in and so on uh where I
said J could have told me oh if you can
prove that uh the set is finite then I
can offer you this proof and then I
would have realized oh I forgot the
finite assumption and my set was finite
right of course so I really wasted one
hour and if you had the two possibly
based on machine learning because these
Pro generate tons of cles don't know
which one is the right machine learning
is
called common one and it's an assumption
we often I mean don't be very hard
machine learning to discover that if you
derive a clause of the form not finite
blah blah blah you know maybe this is
what you should Pro
next right we were we were talking last
year I to see about how how
bmon would recognize when a situation
based Pro goes wrong or goes well and
similar
can that definitely some machine
learning was my question okay so let me
ask the last question so you started the
talk by saying you want to get uh
somehow
intuition and uh you know the results
are getting you know metric SS quite
good like are you making can't on
intuition Sor how are you doing with
intuition you mean how how far is it to
human Intuition or I I I would
say sometimes it does surprising things
it I'm I'm happy that it at least does
this sort of premise selection
reasonably uh the the recent thing with
tactic no you're still talking in terms
of
metrix talking
you you mean how do we measure that we
are close to human
loation good question I I think for that
we should eventually do the informal to
formal bridge and start really looking
at the the
informal I think but is it possible that
you know because you're using cor that
may have lots of ugly proofs on
that
learning stuff that isn't
bad habits yeah that from Bad data you
learn yeah yeah we we definitely from
Bad data we can learn
bading from from data Gooding that's
definitely one of the experiences and we
can combine them in in various ways so
you can never say that one is totally
and one is totally
good okay with that let's
[Applause]